(générique)
---
-Bienvenue dans "Livres et vous",
votre émission littéraire
qui part des livres
pour aller vers vous.
Cette semaine,
je vous emmène sur le terrain,
en compagnie d'un homme politique
lecteur de Karl Marx
et d'un philosophe
défenseur de la liberté.
Le philosophe, Gaspard Koenig,
fait paraître aux éditions
de l’Observatoire,
"Voyages d'un philosophe aux pays
des libertés".
Il enquête sur la tolérance
religieuse en Inde,
sur la libéralisation des drogues
au Colorado,
sur l'usage du microcrédit
dans les bidonvilles de Lima
et sur les prisons ouvertes
en Finlande.
Gaspard Koenig nous rejoindra
en 2e partie de notre voyage.
On commence avec un homme politique
qui fut candidat aux élections
présidentielles de 2002 et 2007.
Il se présente
comme "militant révolutionnaire".
Il fait paraître, chez Fayard,
un ouvrage sur la journée de travail
et le "règne de la liberté"
dont l'enjeu est de montrer
l'actualité de la pensée de Marx,
en plongeant dans les débats actuels
sur le temps de travail.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Bienvenue.
Vous connaissiez
cet endroit ?
-Non, j'y rentre
pour la première fois.
-Impressionnant ?
-C'est un beau cadeau.
Je n'aurais jamais imaginé me sentir
à l'aise dans une salle du Sénat.
Mais celle-ci est à la fois
intimidante et accueillante.
Intimidante,
car on sent le poids de l'Histoire,
à travers tous ces ouvrages.
Accueillante, parce qu'il y a
un côté tranquille, apaisant.
On dirait une cathédrale.
-C'est la présence des livres
qui est apaisante ?
-Je pense, oui.
Et la salle est somptueuse.
J'imagine que ce flot
de connaissance irrigue l'assemblée
qui se trouve juste à côté.
-On le souhaite, en tout cas.
On vous connaît comme militant,
comme candidat présidentiel,
comme facteur, aussi.
On va vous découvrir aujourd'hui
comme auteur,
vous avez déjà beaucoup publié,
et comme lecteur.
Quels rapports entretenez-vous
avec les livres en général
et la lecture en particulier ?
-La lecture,
elle est venue par le biais
de mon engagement militant.
J'ai commencé à agir pour changer
la société, à mon échelle,
à l'âge de 14 ou 15 ans.
Pour ne rien cacher,
c'était plus l'action
qui m'intéressait.
J'y allais un peu tête baissée,
sans trop chercher à réfléchir.
Je pensais qu'il fallait
révolutionner le monde
mais ça n'allait pas
beaucoup plus loin.
J'étais plutôt rétif à l'idée
des grands penseurs, des livres.
Mais on a un problème,
quand on défend
le genre d'idée que je défends,
c'est qu'on tombe vite face à face
à des contradicteurs.
Il y a de nombreux contradicteurs
aux idées que je défends.
Face à des contradicteurs,
on doit opposer des idées.
Il faut aller piocher à gauche
et à droite.
A ce moment, la lecture,
on rentre dedans
et on n'en sort jamais
parce que c'est un puits sans fond,
parce que ça apporte beaucoup.
Ca m'a donné la liberté
de sortir du temps tel qu'il est :
le temps quotidien,
qui nous rend prisonnier
de l'actualité.
Et puis, je crois que c'est
une vraie source d'émancipation.
Pour moi, la révolution
n'est pas une fin en soi.
Je milite pour une autre société,
où les individus
pourraient enfin se faire plaisir,
s'exalter.
Et il y a des choses qu'on peut
prendre ici et maintenant
par le biais de la lecture,
en termes de savoir,
de connaissances, de compétences.
C'est une source d'épanouissement,
d'émancipation.
-C'était donc un rapport utilitaire
à la lecture.
-Oui, dans un premier temps,
il fallait que j'aille opposer
des arguments économiques,
philosophiques,
historiques à tous ceux
qui nous expliquaient que,
ce changement de société,
dans le meilleur des cas,
il n'arrivera pas,
et dans le pire des cas,
il est dangereux.
Ca fait beaucoup de discussions.
Et puis, j'ai eu des rencontres.
Des rencontres de lecture.
On sort actuellement un livre
sur le temps de travail,
le "règne de la liberté" chez Marx,
coécrit avec Michael Lowy.
Et un des livres
qui a compté pour moi,
c'est un livre que Michael
a écrit sur Che Guevara,
qui me parlait par plein d'aspects,
à l'âge de 14 ou 15 ans.
Mais le livre de Michael était
non pas une biographie du Che,
mais sur sa pensée politique.
Et il m'a donné envie
de lire le Che, donc j'ai lu le Che.
J'ai découvert que c'était
tout à fait accessible.
Et en lisant le Che,
j'ai eu envie de lire Marx,
car Che Guevara parle
beaucoup de Marx
d'un point de vue humaniste,
du point de vue de l'individu,
donc très loin des visions
un peu mécaniques
que je pouvais avoir,
liées au passif
de l'idéologie stalinienne.
Tout ce qui s'est passé
dans les pays de l'Est
renvoie quand même une idée
du socialisme froide...
Une espèce de socialisme
de caserne,
où la question de l'individu
n'a pas beaucoup de place.
-Alors, vous avez découvert Marx
par le biais du Che,
mais si on s'intéresse au Che,
figure également controversée,
idéalisé dans une sorte
de romantisme révolutionnaire,
mais qui a aussi beaucoup tué
pour obtenir ce qu'il voulait.
-Il fait la révolution
les armes à la main,
il s'en est jamais caché.
Il écrit sur le thème
de la violence.
C'est le meilleur vaccin.
Y a deux façons de tuer le Che :
dire que c'est un affreux boucher
ou dévitaliser sa pensée
avec cette dose de romantisme.
Le meilleur vaccin,
c'est donc de le lire.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve ?
-Sur la question de la violence,
il était partisan,
dans ses écrits et dans son action,
du fait qu'on n'utilise
la violence révolutionnaire
qu'en cas d'extrême nécessité,
et de pas faire comme les autres.
-Quand décide-t-on que
c'est une extrême nécessité ?
Il a tué des milliers
de collaborateurs.
-Il faut mettre ça dans le contexte
de l'Amérique latine à ce moment-là.
Il y a de nombreux combats
qui prennent justement
les sentiers des montagnes,
pour prendre les armes
contre des régimes dictatoriaux,
financés par l'impérialisme
américain.
Lui explique assez tôt
qu'il faut utiliser
la voie démocratique électorale
jusqu'au bout.
La violence,
on sait quand elle commence,
on sait pas quand elle termine.
Donc y a des contre-feux
à tous ceux qui cherchent pas...
Moi, j'idéalise pas le Che.
En le lisant,
on l'idéalise pas,
on comprend quelqu'un qui,
en temps et en heure,
se pose des problèmes
éthiques colossaux,
qu'a pas une pensée aboutie,
une pensée qu'on pourrait
ériger comme modèle,
mais comme ma conception
de la politique,
c'est d'essayer de piocher
dans tout ce qu'il y a
de meilleur dans les traditions
des uns et des autres,
avec un regard critique,
j'ai découvert là une pensée
critique qui donne envie
de se pencher sur des questions
essentielles.
Y a des textes du Che
sur le socialisme à Cuba,
par exemple,
où il replace la question
de l'individu au coeur
du projet socialiste.
Et c'est un des points
de rupture qu'il a eu
dans son combat
avec les régimes de l'Est,
dans cette période de l'histoire
où y avait l'idée
qu'il existait
un socialisme alternatif
à la fois à ce qui se passait
à Washington,
mais aussi éventuellement Moscou.
Cette troisième voie a compté
pour toute une génération,
pas la mienne,
en l'occurrence,
mais c'est une entrée en matière.
-Avec toute la question,
que vous soulevez,
à propos de Che Guevara,
de savoir si, dans le cadre
d'un engagement communiste,
est-ce que la fin
justifie les moyens ?
Est-ce que,
au nom de la fin recherchée,
tous les moyens
sont bons à prendre,
y compris une certaine violence
qui peut paraître inacceptable
aux yeux des autres ?
C'est un problème éthique.
-La fin justifie pas les moyens,
au regard de ce qui s'est passé,
pas juste dans les caricatures
du communisme qu'ont été
les sociétés staliniennes,
par exemple,
mais aussi dans le monde capitaliste
tel qu'il est,
il faut s'en préserver.
Maintenant,
c'est facile de donner
des leçons à distance
quand on est pas projeté
dans la situation.
Pour moi,
la question de la violence,
et ce que j'en ai compris,
avec le Che, Louise Michel,
c'est l'idée que c'est
de l'autoprotection.
Et c'est pour ça que je me bats,
car ça n'existe nulle part,
à savoir : quand la majorité pourra
enfin décider de son propre sort
dans les questions économiques
et démocratiques,
elle aura en face une minorité
qui se laissera pas faire.
L'histoire regorge d'exemples
pour nous le rappeler,
comme la Commune,
Allende au Chili en 74
qui se termine avec Pinochet.
A chaque fois,
cette minorité privilégiée
se laisse pas faire,
envoie l'armée.
C'est pas juste
des coups de pression,
c'est des régimes
qui se mettent en place,
qui sont dictatoriaux.
Et donc, on pourrait imaginer,
ça pourrait être un cas d'école,
qu'on arrive démocratiquement
à avoir la majorité qui décide
de répartir richesses
et pouvoir entre tous, et puis,
parce qu'on a touché leur bon sens,
cette oligarchie dit :
"On va tout vous livrer car on est
nous aussi des partageux"...
-Vous n'y croyez pas.
-J'y crois pas,
mais tant mieux si ça arrive.
Y aura pas besoin alors
de se poser des questions
de violence révolutionnaire
qui se limitent à la possibilité
pour la majorité
de se protéger de la violence
réactionnaire.
-C'est pour ça que
je vous pose la question
de vos lectures,
car c'est en lisant
que vous avez pu
trouver des arguments
à opposer à vos détracteurs.
Ca a pu solidifier
votre engagement politique.
Parmi les rencontres
que vous avez faites,
y compris littéraires,
y a une rencontre humaine
et une rencontre littéraire.
La rencontre humaine
par un texte
avec le philosophe
Jacques Rancière.
La lecture de ses textes a vraiment
changé quelque chose pour vous.
-Oui, j'ai découvert
Jacques Rancière sur le tard,
sur une question particulière
en lisant un texte
qui s'appelle "Et tant pis
pour les gens fatigués".
Il évoque une question
qu'il développe
dans "Le maître ignorant".
C'est pas ma spécialité,
les sciences de l'éducation,
mais il redéterre les travaux
de Jacotot pour partir d'une idée
absolument révolutionnaire,
qui va à l'encontre de choses
qu'on peut penser assez spontanément
quand on a le coeur à gauche.
Il dit en matière d'éducation :
plutôt que de partir
de l'inégalité présupposée,
il faut partir au contraire
de l'égalité présupposée.
Dans une société inégalitaire,
c'est tentant de vouloir
donner un maximum de moyens
à ceux qui en ont le moins
soit dans les quartiers populaires
et les milieux ouvriers.
Lui dit qu'il ne faut pas faire ça.
Même dans une société inégalitaire,
telle qu'elle est,
il faut partir de l'idée que,
potentiellement,
chacun a des connaissances
et des savoirs et que, le problème,
c'est permettre à ces connaissances
de s'épanouir.
Du point de vue éducatif,
pour moi ça s'arrête là,
parce que je sais pas
si ça peut marcher.
-Ca veut dire que
le professeur lui-même
doit admettre qu'il peut aussi
apprendre de son élève.
-C'est ce qu'il explique
dans "Le maître ignorant",
ouvrage marquant en ce sens.
Alors, peut-on imaginer ce modèle ?
J'en sais rien,
certains le contestent,
avec des arguments
qui peuvent me déstabiliser.
Mais d'un point de vue militant
et philosophique,
ça me parle énormément,
cette idée qu'il faut partir
du registre : ceux qui savent
et ceux qui savent pas.
Dans le bilan critique que je peux
faire de ma propre action,
c'est quelque chose qui vérole
en grande partie des organisations
du mouvement ouvrier,
social
et de la gauche,
y compris radicale,
dans le côté professoral.
Le problème aujourd'hui,
c'est que exploités et opprimés
n'auraient pas compris
ce qui leur arrive.
Or les exploités n'ont besoin
de personne pour comprendre
qu'ils sont dans la merde.
-Mais vous dites
que le savoir et la lecture
vous ont permis d'être plus en phase
avec ce que vous faisiez.
-Mais elle est accessible à tous.
Il faut sortir
de cette espèce de sentiment
de culpabilité
qui renvoie à une situation
de domination.
Finalement, on vit dans une société
qui nous pousse
à nous faire croire,
l'immense majorité,
qu'on est bon à rien,
qu'on est pas apte
à parler de nous-même,
à dérouler nos propres
argumentations,
à développer des idées, les penser,
les relater, les partager.
Moi qui fais beaucoup
de réunions publiques,
on a tous très souvent
la trouille au ventre
avant de parler
dans une réunion publique.
J'ai eu l'occasion en télé
de croiser des politiques
qui sont comme chez eux.
Ils sont sur un plateau télé
comme dans leur salle de bains.
Ils doutent pas, ou en tout cas
c'est l'image qu'ils renvoient,
parce que je crois que,
dans les milieux bourgeois,
on a une forme d'éducation
qui nous porte
à croire qu'on est
dans notre bon droit.
-On peut nuancer aussi.
-Bien sûr.
On peut aussi se dire que la nuance
n'est pas ma spécialité.
J'y vais à coup de serpe,
mais je pense quand même
que c'est une réalité sociale
et sociologique assez forte.
-Mais on va tous à la même école,
en France.
-Loin de là !
-Le programme a priori
s'applique partout.
-Nos responsables sortent souvent
de grandes écoles privées
pour faire la leçon au monde entier.
Mais c'est pas mon propos.
On est des millions à penser
qu'on n'est pas capable de.
Ce qui est fort,
dans les propos de Rancière,
c'est de dire qu'il faut
se faire violence,
se faire violence dans un cadre
où le rapport au partage des savoirs
n'est plus celui qu'on a imaginé.
D'un point de vue militant,
on n'a pas besoin de professeur
rouge, noir, vert ou rose
pour expliquer aux gens
pourquoi ils sont exploités.
Il faut établir des cadres
démocratiques qui permettent
aux uns et aux autres
de se réapproprier cette confiance,
ici et maintenant,
pour élaborer leurs propres propos,
quitte à se tromper.
Je me suis trompé dix mille fois,
j'ai dit des bêtises,
mais toujours avec cette logique
de piocher des idées essentielles
chez les uns et les autres
Je parlais de Marx,
tout à l'heure, là aussi :
on vous parle de Marx
quand vous avez 15 ou 16 ans,
c'est pas que vous partez
en courant, mais...
-Il est difficile à lire !
-Eh ben non, en fait non.
Vous lisez "Le manifeste",
c'est absolument accessible.
Franchement,
c'est pas des salades.
C'était une grande découverte
pour moi de comprendre ça.
Avec des clefs d'entrée différentes,
vous pouvez puiser
dans "Le capital" des passages
très accessibles
et très significatifs,
toujours très parlants.
Donc ma grande découverte,
c'est de me dire que,
ces grands noms
qui m'impressionnaient,
on peut les lire.
Et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont écrit.
Ce barrage-là peut aussi tomber
et c'est des victoires du quotidien.
Se dire que j'ai appris
quelque chose, pour moi,
c'est jouissif.
Après, il faut essayer
de le partager entre tous.
-Et comment faire pour rendre
cet aspect théorique
compatible avec la pratique,
l'engagement ?
Il faut du temps, pour lire.
Il faut des moyens
pour en parler,
diffuser et transmettre
ce qu'on a lu.
-C'est là où ma contribution
se confronte au plafond de verre
de la réalité
de mes propres compétences,
c'est-à-dire que j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer
des militants qui avaient
beaucoup plus de talent que moi
pour partager cette pensée,
et de façon extrêmement généreuse.
Je pense notamment à Daniel Bensaïd,
un militant de mon organisation,
un ami, un grand philosophe,
qui a énormément compté pour moi
et qui était généreux,
dans son écriture ou ses réunions,
pour justement donner envie de.
Lui, il pouvait faire un texte
d'une heure avec des questions
philosophiques,
théoriques de fond,
qu'on a tous.
Vous savez,
quand vous écoutez
quelqu'un et que vous vous dites :
il a dit exactement ce que je pense,
comment il a fait pour mettre
les mots sur ce qu'il y a
quelque part dans ma tête ?
Et à force,
on arrive à le faire
à sa propre échelle,
chacun dans son registre.
-Vous donnez très envie
de lire Marx.
Une autre lecture
que vous m'avez fait découvrir,
c'est un texte d'Emile Zola,
"Mes haines",
qui tient en trois pages.
Et vous me disiez que ce livre
vous avait fait pleurer de rire,
tant il vous a plu.
-On me l'a fait découvrir
il y a très peu de temps.
Déjà, comment dire,
se revendiquer des haines,
c'est pas très tendance,
c'est pas dans l'air du temps !
Là, c'est Zola qui le fait,
donc politiquement, ça passe mieux.
J'ai vraiment pleuré de rire.
Il y a des passages croustillants.
Après, chacun mettra les noms
et les prénoms qui lui parlent.
Mais quand il dit :
"Je hais les gens nuls
"et impuissants,
ils me gênent.
"Ils ont brûlé mon sang
et brisé mes nerfs.
"Je le demande :
que pouvons-nous faire
"de ces gens-là ?
Qu'on nous donne des fous,
"nous en ferons quelque chose.
Les fous pensent,
"ils ont quelque idée trop tendue
"qui a brisé le ressort
de leur intelligence.
"Ce sont des malades de l'esprit
"et du coeur,
des pauvres âmes toutes
"pleines de vie et de force.
Eux, je veux les écouter.
"Mais pour l'amour de Dieu,
et de grâce,
"qu'on tue les sots,
les médiocres,
"les impuissants et les crétins,
qu'il y ait des lois
"pour nous débarrasser
de ces gens-là."
-Ca, c'est inaudible aujourd'hui.
-C'est politiquement pas correct,
mais ça m'a fait tellement rire...
-C'est quasiment élitiste,
comme texte, de dire : tous ceux
que je considère comme médiocres,
il faut s'en débarrasser.
-On peut le lire comme ça,
mais aussi comme une bonne
piqûre de rappel.
Je fais pas partie
de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut dormir sur ses lauriers.
Il faut se faire violence,
se mettre
une aiguille dans le derrière
pour dire que,
si on exige le respect
des puissants,
faut chercher
à se respecter soi-même.
On a le droit à l'erreur,
je revendique le droit de douter,
ça, y a pas de souci,
je pense même que ça peut être
une marque de fabrique
intéressante en philosophie,
mais il faut essayer de s'extirper
individuellement de la condition
dans laquelle on nous enferme.
Il faut pouvoir se dire
qu'on est le premier à être un sot
par plein d'aspects,
car on est tous contradictoires,
mais en même temps,
je revendique et je parie
sur un autre aspect de moi-même.
-Des bienfaits de la haine
comme vecteur
d'une autocritique possible.
On ne la trouve pas
que parmi les référence
que vous avez données,
mais aussi dans le rap,
notamment en la personne
de JoeyStarr,
qu'on va accueillir maintenant
à travers l'écran
au Sénat.
-Et NTM,
ça veut dire quoi ?
-Ca veut dire Nique Ta Mère.
-C'est la seule façon qu'on a
trouvée pour se faire remarquer.
En plus, c'est une expression
qu'on utilise tous les jours,
qui peut être l'équivalent
de "zut" ou "merde".
Y a des gens qui le prennent
au premier degré.
C'est regrettable.
On n'a qu'une vie, alors on s'amuse.
Et en même temps, voilà,
on s'amuse productivement,
en étant productifs.
Je pense pas que ça se dit,
"productivement".
Vous referez le montage :
on s'amuse tout en étant
productifs !
-Est-ce que d'un point de vue
politique,
dans l'engagement politique,
on touche pas plus de gens
par la chanson que par l'écriture ?
-Peut-être, oui.
Par la littérature,
on parlait de littérature,
y a même des convergences
dans la littérature politique.
Padura, par exemple,
ce qu'il écrit,
c'est à la confluence
de la littérature, du roman,
de la politique.
C'est vrai, Jack London,
on retient que "Croc-Blanc",
mais il a écrit
"Le talon de fer",
par exemple.
John Reed, c'est pareil,
avec "Dix jours
qui ébranlèrent le monde".
-Mais personne ne les connaît
autant que JoeyStarr.
-Par la musique aussi,
Jean Ferrat, plein d'autres,
bien sûr, mais moi,
voilà, je suis un militant.
Donc eux,
ils ont véhiculé des idées,
ils ont leur forme d'engagement,
et oui,
JoeyStarr a été plus que productif.
-Ils ont fait entendre
une voix des banlieues,
dont on parle beaucoup en ce moment
avec le plan Borloo
pour sauver les banlieues.
-Je pense qu'ils ont jamais
voulu être les porte-parole
de quoi que ce soit.
Mais c'est le propre des artistes,
il me semble,
de capter l'air du temps.
Quand on capte l'air du temps,
on capte aussi
ce qu'il y a de subversif.
Ils l'ont fait de mille manières
et il le fait encore
de mille manières,
y compris quand il fait
ses "Eloquence à l'Assemblée",
actuellement.
Il le fait à sa manière.
-Essayer de s'adresser
à tout le monde à égalité,
comme vous le disiez avec Rancière,
est-ce que ce qui se passe
en ce moment,
avec ce plan qui vise à réinstaurer
les banlieues
avec les parties de la ville
qui ne sont pas en banlieue,
c'est une même démarche ?
-Depuis que je suis gamin,
j'ai toujours entendu ça.
Moi, ça ne me parle plus.
"On va mettre tout le monde
à pied d'égalité",
ça ne s'est pas fait.
Ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est là où j'ai le plus prise :
dans notre camp social
et politique à nous.
Ca rejoint ce que dit Rancière,
c'est sortir de ce rapport
de subordination,
qui est quand même ancré
dans pas mal d'esprits,
je crois, militants,
encore aujourd'hui,
syndicaux ou politiques :
l'idée que les quartiers populaires
sont des déserts politiques,
et qu'il faut y aller,
surtout pendant les élections.
Y a beaucoup de politique
dans ces quartiers,
au sens large du terme,
c'est des mouvements,
y a des combats, y compris qui sont
nés contre les violences policières,
comme avec la famille
d'Adama Traoré,
avec le combat de sa soeur, Assa,
qui est une famille persécutée,
mais qui mène un combat de famille,
vous savez, on voyait
des combats de ce type-là
aux USA. Quand les mamans parlent
de ce qui se passe à leurs enfants,
ça parle plus grand public
que quand c'est des militants
qui en parlent,
parce que des écoutilles se ferment.
Y a donc de la politique,
et moi, ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est de tisser
des alliances d'égal à égal
sur ce qui nous manque,
aujourd'hui, dans ce pays,
en termes de représentation
politique qui permettrait
aux habitants de ces quartiers
d'être représentés,
aux salariés de l'être,
aux chômeurs de l'être,
mais toujours avec cette idée,
c'est en finir avec ce rapport
de condescendance,
qui consiste, le propre
des politiques est de dire :
"On va aller dans les banlieues
pour dire ce qu'il faut faire."
Mais les gens dans les quartiers,
ils sont grands.
Ils savent,
ils sont les mieux placés
pour savoir ce qu'il leur faut.
-C'est une manière de dire
que l'Etat ne les a pas abandonnés.
-Mais c'est toujours
dans le même rapport,
un rapport de hiérarchie.
On attend de la protection sociale,
pas qu'on décide
à votre place, c'est vrai
pour tout le monde.
-Qu'attend-on de l'Etat
d'un point du vue social,
c'est la question
que vous posez dans ce livre,
"La journée de travail
et 'le règne de la liberté'",
aux éditions Fayard.
La journée de travail,
c'est une expression qu'on trouve
dans "Le capital" de Marx,
et qui formule une idée très simple,
et très précieuse
que vous développez
dans ce livre,
il dit : "Le royaume
"de la liberté commence
avec la réduction
"de la journée de travail."
On serait plus libres
en travaillant moins ?
-Exactement. Ca paraît
une lapalissade et c'est énorme.
-Personne vous contredira.
-J'en suis pas sûr.
Figurez-vous, j'en suis pas sûr.
-Ca veut dire que le travail
est un enfermement.
Ca veut dire que le travail
nous enferme.
-Le travail aliéné,
aujourd'hui, nous enferme.
C'est Michael Lowy, c'est énorme
et c'était enfoui quelque part
dans "Le capital",
parce qu'on avait beau
le relire,
c'est une notion peu traitée
dans "Le capital".
C'est Michael qui me dit :
"Il y a cette phrase,
il faut le traiter à la lumière
de l'actualité." Il a raison.
C'est énorme, mais c'est
on ne peut plus d'actualité,
car aujourd'hui, l'aliénation
au travail sort de l'entreprise,
donc dans une quantité
d'activités professionnelles,
pour ceux qui ont la chance
d'en avoir,
vous sortez du travail en emmenant
votre aliénation avec vous,
avec vos problèmes,
vos problématiques,
vous imaginez votre exploitation
du lendemain.
Et donc la frontière, par exemple,
entre temps libre et temps aliéné,
elle est à revisiter,
y compris parce que
les mouvements sociaux
requestionnent le travail
avec des mouvements
comme les intermittents
et les précaires, qui disent :
"On n'a pas envie de perdre
nos vies à chercher à la gagner,
"on a envie aussi d'espace
de temps et de loisir."
Ces questions reviennent
par rapport aux politiques...
Soi-disant, Macron,
c'est la modernité.
Mais il applique ce que font
les autres depuis 30 ans.
Mais il y a toujours
autant de chômeurs.
Le partage du temps de travail,
c'est une question
que le mouvement ouvrier a lâché
car elle a été discréditée
par l'application de la loi Aubry.
-Les 35 heures.
-L'application
telle qu'elle était faite
des 35 heures.
On disait : "Donnant-donnant".
On a donné l'annualisation
au patronat qui le réclame.
On a perdu sur tous les tableaux.
Mais en Allemagne...
Dans le débat,
je ne veux pas partir loin,
mais les exemples d'autres pays,
on les prend que quand ça arrange
les libéraux.
En Allemagne, les fonctionnaires
sont augmentés de 7 points.
Un syndicat qui n'est pas
d'extrême gauche
fait campagne
pour la semaine de 28 heures.
Vous imaginez les titres
du Figaro ou de L'Express
si un syndicat français voulait ça ?
Donc en réalité, libérer du temps,
c'est pouvoir, là aussi,
chercher à s'épanouir.
Prendre le temps, discuter.
-C'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui.
Mais est-ce que la question
ne serait pas tant celle
de la durée de la journée de travail
que la nature du travail fait ?
En clair, la journée de travail
d'un ouvrier n'est pas
celle d'un professeur,
ni celle d'un agriculteur,
ni celle d'un philosophe
ou un homme politique.
Les journées de travail
sont très variées.
Si on fait un travail
qu'on a choisi, qu'on aime
et qu'on choisit
de travailler beaucoup,
ce sera moins douloureux
de travailler 14h par jour,
comme un écrivain
qui peut faire du 18h.
Ce sera pas la même chose
que celui qui travaille à l'usine
dans un travail imposé,
8h par jour.
Ce n'est pas uniquement
en termes de durée
que la question se pose.
-Je lie les deux.
Il faut lier la nature du travail
et la réduction du temps de travail.
Pour moi, ce qui est aliénant,
c'est pourquoi
cette durée existe ?
Elle existe car le travail
est organisé de telle manière
qu'on est aliéné dans le sens
où les catégories
que vous avez citées
ont un point commun,
au-delà des variations
d'horaire, c'est que vous
travaillez pas pour vous,
à part les écrivains.
-Oui.
-Mais c'est rare.
-La majorité de la société,
aujourd'hui,
elle travaille pour d'autres.
Vous créez
des richesses, des biens,
des services,
qu'on soit prolétaire
dans un atelier, un service,
une plateforme téléphonique ou
livreur, vous créez quelque chose.
Avec votre force de travail
manuelle ou intellectuelle,
vous créez de la valeur ajoutée,
c'est-à-dire qu'entre le moment
où vous êtes arrivé le matin
et le soir,
vous avez créé de la valeur.
Mais ce que vous avez comme salaire,
ce n'est qu'une partie
de cette valeur.
C'est la découverte de Marx
sur la valeur ajoutée
qui est expliquée dans ce livre.
Je pourrais faire de la publicité.
-Vous êtes là pour ça, justement.
-C'est Daniel Bensaïd
qui a beaucoup compté pour moi,
qui avait fait ce livre :
un peu Marx pour les nuls
avec des caricatures de Charb,
à l'époque, où il revient
sur le fameux mystère
de la plus-value,
la grande découverte de Marx,
c'est qu'on est tous volés
de la moitié de la valeur
qu'on donne aux biens
et aux services.
On touche la moitié de cette valeur
sous forme de salaire.
Le restant est volé
par une poignée d'individus.
-Marx le montre très bien
dans "Le capital".
-Tant que le travail sera organisé
comme ça, vous resterez aliénés.
On ne peut pas s'affranchir
de cette aliénation
par une seule réponse.
Il faut désaliéner le travail,
imaginer une autre forme
de travail.
Ce que vous dites peut s'imaginer
dans une autre société.
On travaille pour ce qu'on veut,
pour nous et la collectivité.
-Allons dans des types
de sociétés différentes,
c'est ce qu'a fait Gaspard Koenig,
auteur de "Voyage d'un philosophe
au pays des libertés" aux Editions
de l'Observatoire.
(musique douce)
---
Bonjour, Gaspard Koenig.
Bienvenue dans "Livres et vous".
Vous êtes l'auteur du "Voyage",
mais vous avez aussi
beaucoup d'autres casquettes,
vous avez été plume
de Christine Lagarde en 2007,
fondateur du think-tank
Génération Libre en 2013,
vous êtes aussi écrivain.
Vous avez publié
votre 1er roman à 22 ans.
Vous avez reçu le prix Turgot
de meilleur livre d'économie
pour l'essai
"Le révolutionnaire,
l'expert et le geek".
On vous retrouve aujourd'hui
avec ce livre
qui est une espèce d'enquête menée
autour du thème, et ce n'est pas
que ça, de la liberté,
voir comment
cette belle idée de liberté
est appliquée dans des pays
tels que l'Inde, la Finlande,
et d'autres pays, encore.
Est-ce une manière
de confronter un idéal,
un principe ou un concept
à la réalité ?
-Oui. Quand on est libéral,
on a tendance à se perdre
dans les textes.
Il y en a tant.
J'entendais O. Besancenot qui disait
qu'il était venu aux livres
par l'action, moi, c'est l'inverse.
J'ai commencé par les livres.
C'est vrai qu'on a toujours
le sentiment qu'on flotte un peu
et qu'on parle de choses
qui ne sont pas forcément prouvées,
qui ne sont pas vérifiées.
J'ai voulu prendre des pans
de cette doctrine très complexe
qu'est le libéralisme,
le libéralisme pénal,
le problème de la prison,
que fait-on des religions,
que fait-on du micro-capital,
que fait-on des pauvres,
que fait-on des entrepreneurs,
de tout ça, et à chaque fois aller
dans un pays, un endroit
ou une communauté
qui incarnait, à l'extrême,
disons, ces principes.
Qu'eux-mêmes se revendiquent
libéraux ou pas.
Quand j'ai été voir
les hackers à Berlin,
eux sont plutôt à l'extrême gauche,
quand j'ai été voir
ceux qui veulent
la légalisation du cannabis
au Colorado ne sont
ni de droite, ni de gauche.
Ce n'est pas leur sujet.
Avec les Indiens, c'est d'autres
problèmes. L'idée n'était
pas de rencontrer des libéraux,
mais des gens qui vivent
ce qui je pense
illustrait le mieux les concepts
que je développe.
Et de vérifier un peu
sur le terrain,
de regarder ce qui se passe,
et de parler aux gens
et pas aux intellectuels,
mais plutôt de se fondre
dans des communautés,
de rester assez longtemps,
de faire des reportages
d'une ou deux semaines,
donc on a le temps de parler,
d'errer aussi,
on a le temps
de se laisser surprendre.
On n'a pas un agenda où on fait
3 interviews et on repart.
C'est peut-être d'ailleurs
une des leçons du libéralisme,
ce que John Stuart Mill appelait
le droit à l'errance,
de prendre des chemins de traverse,
de se laisser aller aux surprises.
-Vous dites, dans votre livre :
"Mon libéralisme
n'est ni inné ni naturel.
"Elevé dans la tradition
soixante-huitarde,
"passé par un marxisme adolescent,
fasciné par Deleuze
"et la mystique post-moderne
durant mes études,
"j'ai découvert tard
la pensée libérale
"qui propose fondamentalement
et sous des formes très variées
"de faire confiance à l'individu
et à sa capacité de choix.
Le libéralisme, c'est d'abord
partir de la liberté individuelle ?
-Oui.
La question est :
comment organiser une société
autour de cette liberté ?
Que donne-t-on comme moyens aux gens
pour la réaliser ?
Mille options apparaissent.
Le point de référence,
le mouvement de notre civilisation,
c'est quand même la capacité,
pour l'individu,
de choisir ses propres valeurs,
de choisir sa propre vie.
Dans tous les cas
que j'ai rencontrés,
j'ai trouvé que
ça s'appliquait assez bien.
Quand vous donnez...
C'est un peu toujours
le même principe.
Quand vous donnez
un revenu universel,
qui est quelque chose
que je défends,
et j'ai vu un village brésilien
où on donne ce revenu,
on s'aperçoit que les gens
le dépensent de manière rationnelle.
Quand on donne
de la vraie démocratie directe,
et j'ai été en Suisse
pour voir les cantons qui,
une fois par an, font des votations,
on s'aperçoit que
quand les individus ont le pouvoir,
ils l'utilisent de manière mature.
Quand on donne aux prisonniers,
en Finlande,
un espace de liberté,
et qu'on leur dit :
"Tu as la possibilité de t'enfuir,
"aucun gardien
ne va te tirer dessus,
"mais le contrat moral
qu'on a entre nous
"est de rester dans ce périmètre,
car tu es privé de liberté",
on voit qu'il y a moins d'évasions
que dans les prisons closes.
Quand on donne du crédit
aux gens pauvres,
aux micro-entrepreneurs à Lima...
En fait, le microcrédit,
c'est des crédits
sur des petites sommes,
mais c'est surtout sans collatéral :
le prêteur n'a pas de garantie.
Si l'emprunteur fait défaut,
on ne lui envoie plus son argent.
C'est pareil, on dit :
"Je te fais confiance
"pour me rembourser."
Le taux de défaut
est plus bas
que dans le crédit classique.
C'est un peu le même principe,
sur les prisons,
sur le crédit,
et c'est pareil sur la drogue.
On dit : "On légalise,
"on vous donne l'information."
On s'aperçoit de quoi ?
Que la consommation n'augmente pas
et redescend,
que le taux d'addiction
n'augmente pas.
A partir du moment où vous créez
des structures institutionnelles
avec un système d'incitation
qui donne aux gens
des espaces de liberté,
ils les utilisent
de manière extrêmement responsable.
C'est la leçon du libéralisme,
au-delà des débats économiques
sur le libre-échange,
les grands concepts macro.
Ce qui est intéressant aussi,
dans le macro,
c'est d'aller voir l'individu,
l'humain, ses hésitations
et ses doutes.
-Faire confiance à l'individu,
ça vous parle ?
Le collectif doit primer
sur l'individu ?
-Non, et c'est précisément pour ça
que je suis contre le libéralisme.
Le libéralisme,
avec ses différents aspects
- politiques,
démocratiques et économiques,
parce qu'il y a un tout -
c'est la négation de l'individu.
La société dans laquelle on vit
est libérale, en tout cas
d'un point de vue économique.
Elle crée chez nous des désirs,
des envies...
..que la société ne peut pas
satisfaire pour tous :
l'envie de voyager,
de découvrir... Je parle même pas
des besoins de consommation,
car c'est poussé à l'extrême.
Je crois que, précisément,
il n'y a pas plus grand rempart
à l'épanouissement individuel
que la société libérale.
Après, il y a des exemples
dont vous parlez
du point de vue
des libertés politiques.
Moi, je pars de l'individu.
Mon objectif...
Sous les décombres du stalinisme,
renouer avec une idée de Marx,
c'est aussi
l'épanouissement individuel.
Je vous parlais du Che.
Il expliquait ça.
Il disait justement :
"Dans la société,
"l'homme est dirigé
par un ordre rigide,
"qui habituellement échappe
au domaine de la compréhension.
"L'individu aliéné est lié
à la société dans son ensemble
"par un invisible cordon ombilical :
la loi de la valeur.
"C'est elle qui agit et modèle
tous les aspects de sa vie."
En réalité, c'est une illusion
de liberté individuelle.
Le problème, c'est que
les sociétés bureaucratiques
ont fait,
de l'autre côté du miroir,
exactement la même chose,
c'est-à-dire le côté caserne,
voilà...
Il y a un point d'équilibre
à trouver
entre l'individu et le collectif.
Précisément,
je pense que dans le projet
dont je me réclame,
il y a le fait de ne pas laisser
la question de l'individu
à une version libérale,
égoïste de l'individu.
-Votre livre est
"La journée de travail
et le 'règne de la liberté'".
Quelle est cette liberté ?
-La liberté individuelle.
-Gaspard Koenig en parlait aussi.
-Sur le concept,
ce que je partage pas,
c'est l'idée que ça passe
par le libéralisme,
même si je comprends la démarche.
Je pars de l'idée qu'il faut
se poser la question
de l'épanouissement individuel.
C'est le fil conducteur
de la liberté.
La formule de Marx est
extraordinairement subversive.
C'est la liberté.
C'est précisément
le règne de la liberté.
-D'abord,
vous devez comprendre
que chacun a son utopie.
Les libéraux ont la leur.
Selon Hayek,
il faut une utopie libérale.
Par rapport à cette utopie,
on ne vit pas
dans une société libérale.
La société française actuelle
est étatiste,
totalement règlementée.
Le capitalisme
est dans une large mesure
un capitalisme de connivence.
Ca correspond pas...
Je ne ferais pas le...
Je ne porterais pas ce jugement
sur la société actuelle.
Par rapport à la société actuelle,
je développe un idéal différent,
que des gens essayent d'incarner,
avec des mouvements libertariens.
Il y a une jeunesse
libertarienne puissante,
notamment en Californie,
chez les entrepreneurs
des nouvelles technologies.
Je participe à un projet
où ils essayent de construire
des îles artificielles
en eaux internationales
pour créer des sociétés sans Etat.
C'est pas juste l'acceptation
du statu quo.
Il y a une forte part d'utopie.
En revanche,
cette utopie ne passera jamais
chez nous par la révolution.
-"Nous", c'est qui ?
-Dans la doctrine libérale...
-Pas libertarienne ? Libérale ?
-Il y a tant de...
-Il y a aussi la notion
de libertaire dans le communisme.
-Mon étiquette serait plutôt
libertarien de gauche,
"left libertarian".
Je rentrerai pas dans les détails.
Il y a des débats intéressants
sur ces formes de libertarianisme.
Il y a une différence de principes
entre le libertarien de gauche
et de droite.
Le libertarien de droite va dire,
et c'est le truc lockéen :
"Ce que je m'approprie
par mon travail devient moi."
Chez le libertarien de droite,
classique, rothbardien,
les ressources naturelles
ne sont pas appropriées,
donc ce que je m'approprie
est le mien.
Du coup, l'impôt est
du travail forcé.
Chez le libertarien de gauche,
les ressources naturelles
dont je m'empare par mon travail
sont appropriées
par l'ensemble du groupe,
et je dois dédommager le groupe
de ce que je lui retire.
Du coup, il y a de la place
dans cette philosophie
pour la redistribution.
C'est pas un hasard
si le revenu universel
est réclamé par énormément de gens
dans les mouvements libertariens.
-Pourquoi êtes-vous
pour le revenu universel de base ?
-Il y a une première approche
qui est de lutter
contre la pauvreté.
Je fais une distinction nette
entre lutter contre la pauvreté
et contre les inégalités.
Les inégalités ne sont pas
un problème dans une société.
Le problème est la pauvreté.
Le revenu universel a effectivement
des effets redistributifs :
on prend l'argent quelque part.
Dans mon think-tank,
on essaye de modéliser
ces belles idées
en actions publiques très concrètes.
On a trouvé l'impôt nécessaire
pour financer ce schéma,
qui est possible en France,
mais l'idée est de sortir
de suite les gens de la pauvreté,
car c'est un revenu
que tout le monde touche.
Il y a pas des gens...
Actuellement, le RSA,
ça marche très mal.
Il faut remplir des formulaires.
Le tiers des bénéficiaires
potentiels ne l'ont pas.
C'est très bureaucratique
et humiliant pour les gens.
Là, tout le monde
a une somme d'argent.
-Quelle somme ?
Parce que si c'est une petite somme,
on sort pas de la pauvreté.
-C'est une somme qui doit couvrir
les besoins de base,
sans déstabiliser
le système économique actuel,
sans révolution.
Je n'aime pas les révolutions.
Et ensuite,
l'idéal ultime, c'est d'arriver,
comme dit Philippe Van Parijs,
à la somme maximum soutenable.
C'est-à-dire soutenable sans enrayer
les mécanismes qui permettent
l'innovation et la création
de richesses, et maximum
dans ce cadre, pour permettre,
et c'est ce qui est libéral,
l'autonomie de l'individu,
c'est-à-dire pour fonder...
Les libertariens redécouvrent
la liberté réelle chère à Marx :
on ne peut pas juste dire
qu'il y a des libertés négatives,
et que tant qu'on peut faire
ce qui ne nuit pas à autrui,
on est libre, et basta.
Il faut assurer
la substance matérielle
de cette liberté.
Il faut donc donner de l'argent.
L'argent est ce qu'il y a
de plus simple et de plus beau
dans ce cas-là,
car il vous permet
de faire vos propres choix.
Quand vous avez une somme,
vous la dépensez comme vous voulez.
Vous arbitrez vos besoins.
Ca paraît très théorique,
mais c'est pour ça
que je suis allé voir les gens
qui le reçoivent au Brésil,
pour vérifier, leur parler.
Au Brésil, les gens recommencent
à parler au futur.
Ils parlaient au présent,
car ils devaient survivre.
Comme cette somme
est inconditionnelle
et sans limite dans le temps,
les gens recommencent à se projeter
et à entreprendre
ou ne pas entreprendre.
Ca donne le choix du travail
et du non-travail.
Par rapport à ce que vous dites,
c'est une réponse très puissante
à l'idée de l'aliénation.
-Que pensez-vous
du revenu universel de base ?
-Je n'y suis pas favorable.
Je milite
pour la protection sociale,
pour une allocation d'autonomie
pour tous les jeunes en formation.
Je propose une branche
de la Sécurité sociale
avec interdiction des licenciements
pour que les salariés bénéficient
de la même rémunération,
avec un fonds
financé sur les grandes entreprises.
L'idée de l'allocation...
C'est le noeud de la contradiction,
maximum, minimum...
Pour sortir de la pauvreté,
il faut affronter le rapport
entre le capital et le travail.
L'argent, vous ne le prenez pas
nulle part,
mais en fonction de ceux qui,
aujourd'hui,
détiennent les capitaux.
Si on veut que ça soit
autre chose qu'une aumône...
Je dis ça,
parce qu'il y a eu un débat.
Benoît Hamon défendait
cette idée-là.
Si c'est l'idée qu'on peut esquiver
la confrontation capital-travail
par ce biais-là,
on peut être sûr...
-C'est une manière de pas prendre
le problème à la racine ?
-Oui, et on va
vers une nouvelle aumône
qui va rien régler
au problème de la pauvreté.
On traite la question
du revenu universel.
On explique pourquoi
on n'est pas d'accord avec ça.
L'aliénation étatique vaut largement
l'aliénation salariale.
Après, c'est des questions
de concepts,
mais il faut financer,
on est bien d'accord.
Vous-même imaginez
une forme de fiscalité.
Qui dit forme de fiscalité
dit forme de collecte.
Qui dit forme de collecte
dit forme étatique.
J'emploie le terme
de façon générale.
-Il ne faut pas
d'intervention de l'Etat,
à ce niveau-là ?
-Moi, mon projet,
c'est une société anticapitaliste,
antibureaucratique,
qui trouve des formes
de collectivité,
je dirais des formes étatiques
avec le plus petit "e" possible.
En effet, la question
des ressources naturelles
est inévitable.
Sauf à penser que vous avez
un rapport partout égalitaire
entre l'individu préétabli
et les ressources naturelles...
Je souhaite à quiconque
de me démontrer ça.
Si vous pensez pas ça,
c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des régions
mieux pourvues que d'autres
et que, compte tenu
des enjeux écologiques,
il y a des degrés de coordination
entre les populations à trouver...
Qui dit degrés de coordination
dit forme étatique.
Le problème est de trouver
une forme
d'organisation démocratique
la plus antibureaucratique possible,
la plus contrôlée par le bas.
C'est ce qu'on essaye de traiter,
sans répondre sur tout,
mais en tous les cas
avec des réponses
qui portent un nom : la démocratie.
-Vous voyez l'aspect sensible
avec l'argument de l'étatisation.
Le revenu universel
permet d'avoir l'Etat
le plus maigre possible.
C'est un dispositif automatique.
Dès qu'on a décidé du niveau,
le politique n'a plus à intervenir.
C'est un processus
qui est complètement mécanique.
-Mécanique ? C'est-à-dire ?
C'est pas une machine.
-Non, mais c'est des règles.
C'est purement fiscal.
Je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
de cette chose-là.
Si vous avez un impôt sur le revenu
qui est déterminé
que vous avez un crédit d'impôt
qui constitue le revenu universel,
vous faites la différence
entre les deux,
vous n'avez plus de groupes.
C'est la même chose pour tous.
C'est très simple.
15 fonctionnaires au Trésor
peuvent le faire.
La décision politique,
c'est sur le niveau du revenu.
Ensuite, c'est plus simple
que ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui.
Sur le capital et le travail,
ce qui est...
Vous faites une belle analyse.
Effectivement,
je pense que l'idéal libéral
décrit par Foucault,
quand Foucault parle de Becker,
et ça va vous faire bondir,
c'est que chacun devienne à lui-même
sa propre entreprise,
que chacun devienne à lui-même
son propre capital.
C'est ce que j'ai vu
avec le microcrédit à Lima.
L'idée est :
au lieu de vous mettre
dans une forme salariale
où il y a extorsion
de la valeur produite
par le travail par le capital,
comment vous êtes à vous-même
et vous construisez du capital ?
Au lieu de s'attaquer au capital,
comment on dissémine le capital ?
C'est toute l'idée d'H. De Soto
par rapport au tiers-monde.
Je l'ai rencontré à Lima.
Je l'admire.
Il a dit : "Le problème
du tiers-monde n'est pas
"que le capitalisme l'exploite,
"c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
de capitalisme."
Il y a du capitalisme réduit
aux multinationales,
mais les pauvres
sur les collines de Lima
n'ont pas de titre de propriété.
Leur maison n'est pas du capital.
-Mais on peut penser la propriété
sans le capital.
C'est pas la même chose.
On peut dire
que l'argent n'est pas
le capitalisme.
-Il assimile,
et je suis assez favorable à ça,
car ça rejoint les questions
des data, les données.
C'est l'idée
que le droit de propriété
est une invention absolument magique
pour faire advenir le capital,
et qu'une possession que vous avez,
sur laquelle vous n'avez pas
le droit de propriété,
comme les bidonvilles,
vous n'avez pas vraiment
de flexibilité avec.
Vous pouvez pas en sortir.
Il faut compter sur vos voisins
pour la protéger.
Ca peut pas devenir un titre.
C'est pour ça que le combat
du cadastre a été aussi important
au cours de notre histoire,
aux 18e-19e siècles.
Unifier le cadastre a été nécessaire
à la naissance du capitalisme
pour précisément transformer
ce que les gens possédaient
de manière habituelle,
en capital
qu'on peut abstraire,
donc qu'on peut ensuite...
qu'on peut vendre,
qu'on peut diviser entre héritiers,
qu'on peut faire fructifier,
transférer ou non,
parce que la loi de propriété
permet aussi de sortir du marché.
J'en viens au dernier point
dans ce que vous décrivez :
un idéal qui est le vôtre,
où les gens,
je l'ai lu dans votre livre, font...
ont du temps
pour faire de la musique,
de la culture,
pour s'épanouir personnellement,
mais moi, ce que je redoute,
c'est d'imposer...
..un idéal personnel,
à l'ensemble d'une population.
-Vous faites pareil.
-Non. L'idée, c'est de...
-Si chacun défend
une utopie, c'est le propre
de la politique aussi.
-Oui, mais l'idée,
c'est de garantir les moyens
pour que chacun fasse
ses choix de valeurs.
-Vous dites
autre chose.
-S'il y en a qui veulent
s'épuiser au travail
et gagner des millions,
pas de problème.
Si d'autres veulent
sortir du système,
ils ont le revenu universel
pour le faire.
Je veux une société
où les choix de valeurs...
Le revenu universel permet...
-Chacun fait
ce qu'il veut.
Une société capitaliste
ne permet pas
à chacun de faire ce qu'il veut.
Celui qui choisit de le faire
en impose...
-C'est ce que
j'essaye de défendre,
et montrer comment on peut
construire ce genre de modèle,
et comment on peut construire aussi
des institutions,
c'est pour ça que je suis pas
contre toute forme d'Etat,
comment on peut construire
des formes d'institutions
qui guident les gens, quelque part,
vers une forme de libertés
et de responsabilités.
-On voit en tout cas que
c'est autour du thème
de la liberté
que vos pensées se rejoignent.
Et on voit à quel point
le terme de "liberté"
peut être investi
de manière très différente.
Vous avez apporté, à ma demande,
trois livres, de chevet,
des livres qui ont compté pour vous
et qui nous permettent
de comprendre quelles sont
les références culturelles
voire littéraires
qui vous nourrissent.
-J'ai pris les livres qui sont
vraiment sur ma table de chevet,
que j'ai pas encore finis.
-J'espère que c'est pas indiscret.
-Vu le début, je pense que...
..je vais aimer la fin.
C'est "Skin In The Game",
de Nassim Taleb,
qui avait écrit "Black Swan",
qui est une sorte de...
C'est un auteur libanais,
un humaniste comme on les aime,
un peu mathématicien,
un peu financier,
qui voyage beaucoup,
une grande personnalité.
La thèse du livre :
pour parler de quelque chose,
il faut avoir un peu...
Avoir un peu maille à partir,
mettre sa peau dans le jeu,
mettre sa peau en jeu.
Et donc, il explique que finalement,
il est absolument nécessaire
à toute conception intellectuelle
d'être directement mise à l'épreuve
de la pratique, ce que j'ai essayé
de faire avec mes voyages.
Ca tombait bien.
Le deuxième, c'est pour moi
la meilleure histoire intellectuelle
du libéralisme,
qui a été écrite par...
C'était le cours de Michel Foucault
au Collège de France en 78-79,
qui a été édité sous le titre
de "Naissance de la biopolitique".
Foucault entretient une relation
très paradoxale avec le libéralisme.
Au début, ça fait partie
de son histoire de la vérité.
On voit,
quand il commence le livre,
qu'il a une grande distance
par rapport au libéralisme,
mais plus ça va, plus on sent
des points de conjonction, notamment
avec l'idée du revenu universel,
ou l'impôt négatif,
quand il parle de Friedman,
et qu'il apprécie
ses aspects antidisciplinaires.
Avec Becker, ils se rejoignent.
C'est étonnant comment
des libéraux américains radicaux
rejoignent la gauche alternative
deleuzo-foucaldienne française.
Ils ne se connaissent pas.
Becker et Foucault pensent presque
la même chose sur le plan pénal.
L'idée d'illégalisme, par exemple,
qu'il y ait des poches de non-droit
qu'une société doit tolérer
est quelque chose
que Becker va concevoir
et que Foucault approuve aussi.
-Et votre troisième livre ?
-Il ne faut pas oublier la mort.
-Personne ne l'oublie,
rassurez-vous.
-Finalement, des fois,
on se dit :
"On parle beaucoup,
on oublie la vanité."
Un moyen de s'en rappeler,
c'est de lire et de relire...
-Jean Giono.
-Qui est un
de mes auteurs préférés,
qui n'a rien de libéral.
Dans mes activités d'écrivain,
j'écris des choses qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ce que je pense,
notamment le roman sur la Roumanie,
qui est tout l'inverse,
l'histoire de l'exploitation
par le travail.
-Dites-nous, ce livre ?
-"Un roi sans divertissement"
est basé sur la phrase de Pascal,
"Un roi sans divertissement est
un homme plein de misère."
Et il explore comment,
finalement,
face à la vanité des choses,
au fait que même si nous,
on ne meurt pas,
les transhumanistes auront
augmenté notre cerveau,
le soleil disparaîtra.
On peut aller sur Mars,
mais ça commence à faire
un pari pascalien très peu probable.
Et que donc, finalement,
le seul moyen
de garder un sens à sa vie,
c'est l'esthétique,
et chez Giono, ça va très loin.
C'est l'esthétique du meurtre
qui ouvre le livre,
meurtre humain ou animal,
avec la chasse aux loups,
et à la fin, le héros se fait...
se suicide, en fait,
dans un feu d'artifice
comme un acte esthétique ultime,
pour ne pas avoir
à devenir lui-même criminel.
-Vous avez spoilé le livre. Enfin,
ça donne envie de lire
tout ce qui y conduit.
Merci beaucoup, Gaspard Koenig.
Olivier Besancenot, vous avez évoqué
vos livres, mais pas tous,
j'en vois un dont on n'a pas parlé.
-Camus,
"Le mythe de Sisyphe",
que j'ai lu très récemment.
Je ne l'avais pas lu.
Ca traite de la question
du suicide,
qui dit que c'est la seule question
philosophique qui vaille.
-C'est le début du livre.
-Le début du livre,
qui est une entrée en matière
forte et puissante,
qui...
..qui dénonce le monde de l'absurde
en expliquant que l'absurde
vient de la rencontre
entre notre quête sonore de sens,
et puis, le silence du monde
qui nous entoure.
C'est-à-dire notre appel à vouloir
trouver un sens aux choses,
individuellement et collectivement,
et ce monde qui nous entoure
et de là naît l'absurde.
Le seul moyen de lutter
contre l'absurdité,
c'est la révolte.
Une bonne piqûre de rappel.
Et celui-là, dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure, en BD.
C'est aussi un clin d'oeil à Charb
et Daniel, qui nous ont quittés.
-Daniel Bensaïd.
-Daniel Bensaïd, voilà.
-Dessiné par Charb.
-Voilà.
C'est... en quelques dessins
et en quelques pages,
l'illustration qu'on ne peut pas
avoir un système capitaliste
rempli de capitalistes.
On peut pas tous devenir
capitalistes dans le système.
-Drôle d'idée.
-Je sais bien.
Voilà, donc c'est une illustration
de tout ça,
et puis, Rancière :
"Tant pis pour les gens fatigués".
Il faut continuer.
-Le titre : "Et tant pis
pour les gens fatigués".
-"Et tant pis
C'est un recueil d'entretiens
où Rancière, en détails,
revient sur ses travaux
et donne envie de le découvrir,
même s'il y a des choses
avec lesquelles on peut discuter.
Un point de vue
qui fait du bien.
-Merci de nous donner envie
de lire ces livres.
Merci d'être venus
parler de vos ouvrages.
Olivier, avec Michael Lowy,
"La journée de travail et le règne
de la liberté" chez Fayard.
"Voyages d'un philosophe aux pays
des libertés",
aux éditions de L'Observatoire.
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine.
On se quitte,
comme chaque semaine, en chanson.
Un hymne. On se quitte
en chanson, un hymne à la liberté.
-Manu Chao.
-Pas Manu Chao,
mais Nina Simone,
qui aimerait savoir
à quoi ça ressemble
le fait d'être libre.
-I wish I knew how
It would feel to be free
I wish I could break
All the chains holding me
I wish I could say
All the things that I should say
Say 'em loud say 'em clear
For the whole round world to hear
00:53:08,960 --> 00:53:08,800
I wish I could share All the love
that's in my heart
I wish I could share
All the love that's in my heart
Remove all the bars
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA